islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
[Music]
i started a journey
and i'm nowhere near the end with every
stumble
there's a lesson to be learned and i got
a message
and i want it to be heard with all the
promises that life can learn i got the
word on my shoulders
[Music]
but we don't care we have a love in our
hearts and
[Music]
when we fall down we get up we got that
vision
mountain
[Music]
we got that vision
[Music]
[Music]
don't lose inspiration
don't be hard on yourself you're one in
a billion
you motivate the ones you love you got
your own way
you're finding places no one finds you
right at the
where is the save iman norway masjid i
can't see it where is it
relax relax alhamdulillah we've
purchased this huge 2 700 square meters
building with this huge seven half
thousand square meters of land and
insha'allah with your help we are going
to convert this huge property into the
most epic islamic center in the whole
country of norway and this is not one of
those one of ajit projects where you
give your sadaka and you get the reward
for that one specific deed that you
donated towards now this is a sadhaka
geria that will keep on giving you
rewards for as long as this masjid
stands which can be hundreds of years in
sha allah click the button to donate
whatever you can
[Music]